a warning from these protesters mostly
students to India's Hindu nationalists
that violence will not keep them from
the streets but will only strengthen
their resolve on Sunday masked men armed
with rods and sticks stormed the
Jawaharlal Nehru University campus in
New Delhi attacking students and staff
rival leftist and white wing student
groups have been sparring over a hike in
university accommodation fees for weeks
but too many Sunday's brazen attack in
one of India's leading universities is
unprecedented absolutely shocked because
each University in India and there's a
group of about 50-60
young men armed with wooden sticks with
their faces covered and very calmly
getting ready for an attack I spend my
entire life on the campus I've never
seen anything so incredible
protesters are accusing a Student Union
linked to Prime Minister Narendra Modi's
ruling party agenda bottie it has denied
the accusations
please blamed for not doing enough to
stop the assault say they are
investigating what happened as far as
the identification of people who were
participating in the clashes all
possible methods of identification are
being invoked we are also keeping an eye
on the messages videos and pictures
circulating on social media students and
campuses across India came together in
solidarity some turned violent in
Kolkata protesters from another top
university faced off with BJP activists
and the police
SiC where have we come to I mean
violence and universities I cannot even
imagine this I felt so safe when I was
studying in college and what are we
giving to our students
it's the latest in a series of
crackdowns against students in recent
weeks over India's controversial
citizenship law which many say
discriminates against Muslims this
attack seems to be only uniting them
further against the government Priyanka
Gupta al-jazeera